here we go folks happy Thursday I am
Nick Gillespie I'm an editor at Large
uh
I am an at a larger reason magazine I am
joined by my esteemed colleague Zach
weismuller and this is our weekly reason
live stream we are talking today with
Ethan nadelman he is the founder and
former head of the drug policy Alliance
uh before that he was a political
science professor at Princeton
University in a uh a distant life and a
very different America Ethan thank you
for talking to reason today now it's my
pleasure Nick and good to meet you Zach
we are we're going to be talking about
uh our you know our subject for the next
hour hour and a half is legalize all
drugs nobody is better positioned to
talk about that better qualified than
Ethan nadelman
um we live in a world that is uh you
know where we've been Waging War on
Drugs on illegal drugs illicit drugs the
government calls them uh going back at
least to the very very early 70s with
Richard Nixon when he talked about a War
on Drugs but the the War on Drugs in
America actually goes back to the
Colonial founding if we want to get you
know kind of really historical about it
with all kinds of laws about imbibing
tobacco and alcohol and all of that
we're going to be talking uh you know in
the 20th century uh law started getting
passed in the early part of the century
in order to curb uh use of certain kinds
of Narcotics and and various patent
medicines and things like that in the
30s we saw a a Banning of marijuana
typically and all of these things and I
think most of these people know most
people watching know that drugs would be
associated with some kind of subgroup
that was not liked it could be uh
Negroes cocaine Negroes the New York
Times used to write a lot about in the
teens and 20s marijuana was identified
with Mexicans LSD uh in the 60s with
young people
but you you identify bad drugs with bad
people and then seek to control them
um Ethan can you talk about what's been
happening over let's say since the mid
90s since 1996 when California first
legalized medical marijuana a few years
later it uh it has legalized
recreational marijuanas have a bit more
than a dozen states
um where are we in the drug war and I
apologize I'm I'm speaking in lower
Manhattan so the occasional uh you know
large truck we'll probably hear police
sirens and a couple of Screams of people
uh but Ethan uh give us the measure of
where we are in terms of the drug war
Circa 2023. who's who's winning who are
the who are the combatants and are we
winning or losing the drugs sure sure
Nick let me just start off by saying I
should probably move the upper west side
it's much quieter up here we rarely hear
those sirens and all sorts of things you
know that's because it's dead that's it
means it's a graveyard yeah you have a
Central Park Riverside Park you're stuck
down in the middle of all that concrete
uh anyway I didn't move to New York in
order to hang out in fake nature please
continue sir a matter of balance right
you know
um so anyway the answer is Nick I mean I
think there's definitely been
significant progress since the 90s um
but obviously a long way to go and I'm
talking both U.S internationally
um I mean yeah it's obviously the most
dramatic transition has been with
cannabis right I mean when I got going
this in the late 80s you know there were
marijuana was not legal anywhere for
anything not MediCal not anything and
maybe 28 of the country thought we
should Legalize It And barely 50 is
always Legalize It for medical and
beginning in 1996 with the ballot
initiative in California and going up to
the present you know we're now at a
point now we're over 65 percent of
Americans say make marijuana legal
um you know something like 90 they make
it legal for medical purposes you're
even getting a majority of Republicans
in many states and certainly among young
Republicans uh there's a sense of
inevitability right I mean you had what
over was it well over half the country
now has legal access to marijuana
um uh I mean you know and about half of
all Americans have tried marijuana at
least once in their lifetime yeah half
of all adult adult Americans or you know
over the age of 16 or whatever
um but the thing that's remarkable about
that of course is that we did in the
United States I mean because you think
about it we were the evil empire of the
global war on drugs for the last hundred
years and yet nonetheless the same
country which had the most oppressive
drug policy of any Democratic Society
and criminal justice policy in the
history of democratic societies and
which has been the global champion and
proselytizer of the War on Drugs we
nonetheless became the world leader when
it came to legally regulating cannabis
first for medical purposes and then more
broadly and I think that was because we
pursued you know a very sort of
disciplined and thoughtful strategy
about putting medical marijuana first I
think we're aided by the fact that our
opponents the drug czar's office the
federal government the D.A were so
extreme in sort of mocking the medical
value of marijuana that they essentially
lost any sort of credibility they had
even with people in the center so the
marijuana reform has been absolutely
dramatic there's obviously too many
arrests still going on you know it's
bizarre that even I remember in New
Jersey which is legalized a year or two
ago even as you had a substantial
majority of New Jersey and saying let's
do it already let's legalizing they just
couldn't quite get it through the
legislature nonetheless the police were
arresting more and more people from
marijuana position every year so you
still have a problem especially in the
South and some other states of
significant marijuana arrests there is
that racial bias that sort of just woven
into the DNA of marijuana policy all
around the country so that's there but
Monumental success something that people
could not have been predicted I don't
think 10 15 15 years ago or so the
second area in terms of reducing the
role of the drug war and mass
incarceration we've had a lot of
progress there as well I mean the the
War on Drugs was The Cutting Edge of the
movement towards mass incarceration
1980s and 90s it was the thing driving
things places like New York DC and New
Jersey 40 to 50 percent of all new
commitments to prison back in those days
were for Drug law violations you know
but you get to the end of the century
early 20 you know early 2000s and um and
basically you're talking about about a
half a million people out of a total
incarcerated population of 2.2 2.3
million are there on Drug law violations
where that's the first charge and then
if you add in all the things where it's
a secondary charge or you add all the
things where people are being violated
parole and probation but not being
counted as a drug offender when they're
reincarcerated all the people getting
caught up in violent struggles between
drug dealers and getting involved you
know put getting put in for a homicide
or assault you know all the people
stealing to support their habits which
are more expensive because they're
illegal so we've now taken that number
down I don't know the exact numbers but
the numbers locked up on for Drug law
violations has really dropped very
substantially from that half a million
and it's not been seen as the driving
element in mass incarceration now for at
least a few decades so can you talk a
little bit the other place where there's
a lot of movement uh in the past uh you
know decade or so and certainly just in
the 2020 elections uh which 20 uh excuse
me midterm 2020 well 2020 and 2022 but
the decriminalization or the loosening
up of uh of uh laws related to mostly
plant-based psychedelics so things like
mushrooms uh and there's also you know
legal movement to uh to make MDMA and
psilocybin the uh the psychoactive agent
in mushrooms available in certain kinds
of medical clinical trials and things
like that talk a little bit about kind
of what's happening on the Psychedelic
uh sure sure I mean and Truth is Nick
the other era I was going to mention was
the third area of harm reduction
um but we can get back to that later
yeah yeah exchange problems reduce AIDS
overdose prevention that's the other
place where we've seen significant
change but not nearly as significant as
marijuana or even with with reducing the
role of the drug or mass incarceration
the psychedelics don't play in very much
of course to the whole issue of mass
incarceration relatively few people are
getting arrested much of us going to
jail or prison I mean I don't know if
the numbers amount to the 100 or perhaps
the low thousands nationally
um obviously there are some major you
know dealers and producers who have
spent long amounts of time there's a
whole kind of Grateful Dead and I don't
know does fish have a whole psychedelic
element to it I'm not sure uh but you
know it's um you know I mean there's the
people who are you know who are still
getting busted but it's it's a minor
minor element when it comes to the
criminal justice system What's
significant there
is really that there's these two tracks
that you've mentioned one is this
extraordinary explosion this psychedelic
Renaissance of of research you know a
lot of it funded unfortunately not by
the government but by Private Industry
which is going to distort the way this
whole thing emerges in various respects
but nonetheless I mean you look at
Harvard Yale Johns Hopkins University of
California you know Texas Alabama
Florida University College London I mean
you name it I mean major research
institutes looking into the potential
medical psychological uh benefits of
psychedelics and that was inconceivable
just 10 years ago in fact even when I
stopped running drug policy Alliance six
years ago we could not have imagined
this sort of transition the work that
Maps is doing where they're probably
going to get MDMA you know AKA ecstasy
or Molly which is not technically a
psychedelic it's more of what's called
an empathogen but that's likely to be
approved by the FDA in the next year
year and a half or so and then
separately it looks like psilocyte
private the key ingredient magic
mushrooms May well be approved because
other efforts going forward and I think
we're going to see that this is not
going to stop I mean the evidence about
the benefits of these substances and
dealing certainly with emotional
psychology psychological issues but also
potentially even physical issues I mean
it really is extraordinary and it's one
reason why you have hard scientists
sounding like enthusiasts when they talk
about this stuff the parallel angle is
the decriminalization model right
basically it's a it's the more
Grassroots psychedelics movement picking
up on what we did with marijuana reform
beginning in the 90s which are local
referendum first at the city level then
at the state level now in Oregon and
Colorado basically saying people should
be allowed to grow their own people
should be able to use this thing in a
religious or other types of things this
should not be regulated by the state you
know just like let's just pull the state
back from this and we're not going to
open up retail sale of psychedelics but
we are going to allow almost everything
short of that and there's a kind of
radical element of that part of it which
I love another part which is kind of
being politically blind to you know the
broader political context because we
don't want to see this stuff kind of
rolling backwards but that's been
significant in terms of people's broader
Consciousness I think the major element
is just that there's a reduced fear
around this stuff I mean you and I many
other people are far more open talking
about our psychedelic use even people
who don't have some public profile in
this issue I mean you know the Michael
Collins book I mean that's just excited
massive interest the media coverage has
been overwhelmingly favorable so far
there's been relatively few kind of you
know stories of people jumping off
buildings because they were flipping out
on psychedelics and so if I could fly so
I mean that's that lies that still lies
in the future it'll swing around again
and it really does but I think we're a
lot further along now compared to the
previous psychedelic Renaissance in the
late 50s and early 60s where there was
also overwhelmingly positive media a lot
of excitement about scientific research
but it was not as broad-based it didn't
raise rest on the basis of the major
marijuana reforms which provided a model
so I think we're we're in an area where
any role back in this area is going to
be modest and I think there's a lot of
room to still keep running forward I
want to just very quickly point out that
you know uh Michael pollen one of the
ways that I've thought about it is
Michael pollan's book how to change your
mind kind of made psychedelics as well
as you know weed was already okay but it
made psychedelics okay for the NPR crowd
and um one of the things that's very
makes NPR much better is to listen to it
while you are on psychedelics
can we return uh to what you were saying
at the very beginning there for a second
Ethan about marijuana legalization and
the changing attitudes towards that over
time I'm pulling up a graph here the
Gallup poll that has tracked that since
the since 1970 you see starting at 12
percent around 1996 which is when the
medicalization uh went into effect in uh
California you see that upward
trajectory from 25 percent all the way
to about 68 according to the latest
polling data of people who agree with
legalizing marijuana and you mentioned
it's even higher when you talk about for
medical purposes I wonder you know since
marijuana is the most you know popular
recreational drug aside from alcohol
are there limits to the lessons that we
can infer from that uh when we talk
about pushing decriminalization or
legalization to yeah drugs that are less
popular or you know might have a greater
risk profile
um so like what are the lessons that you
would draw from the success of marijuana
legalization and what are the limits to
those lessons Okay Executives to be fair
that's an excellent question but just
pull up that chart again and I want to
know just two comments about it one is
the people watching this may notice or
listening I'll describe that there was a
period in the late 70s when the numbers
went up to what is it at 28 or something
before that's wrong to 23 and that was
up here in the late 70s where 11 states
decriminalized marijuana possession
where President Jimmy Carter basically
called for the federal decriminalization
of marijuana there were medical
marijuana kind of quasi-research
statutes passing around the country and
it was a point where a lot of people
thought that was the you know late 70s
was when I was in call College it was
appear a lot of people thought that
marijuana legalization was inevitable
but I bring that up because you know in
fact it shows you that things can roll
backwards it also shows you that the
early generation of Advocates I'm
thinking especially you know normal
played a very important role there they
kind of got ahead of themselves they
thought that getting a normal just to uh
say normal is the National Organization
for the reform of marijuana laws yes and
it was a key in the 1970s a very
significant force in sort of
popularizing the liberalization of
marijuana laws it almost kind of went
under in the 80s and then it's been out
there since that time as a kind of the
leading organization in terms of
representing the voice of the marijuana
consumer right not as politically active
in many places his drug policy Alliance
and marijuana policy project but really
a bigger reach on the social media front
but so it shows you that you know we
have to be careful imagine just because
quote unquote every you know we used to
say oh everybody everyone in college was
smoking pot but in fact it wasn't it was
half for 40 back in the day you know so
we have to be careful about that the
other thing Zach about that um gallopol
if you were to take out the Gallup poll
on support for support for legalizing
gay marriage right you would see that
the line almost is the exact same
um as it is for legalizing marijuana I
mean these two are the major issues that
emerged primarily out of the progressive
left end of the political Spectrum but
managed to cross over enough to become
basically National you know National
policy in different one way or another
right and if you if you break it down a
little further you would see that the
one significant difference between the
two is that is that the the marijuana
legalization thing would get something
like 70 or 70 percent of Democrats and
maybe 30 percent of Republicans gay
marriage would get 80 percent of
Democrats but maybe only 20 percent of
uh legalizing gay marriage right
um uh of legalized marijuana so so you
you'd see a little basis where we the
marijuana move was better able to cross
over to the Republican conservative side
than was the gay marriage thing right
but I I want to point out because
because this is reason and it's a
Libertarian uh you know outfit it was
actually Libertarians were always
pushing for marijuana legalization as
well as gay marriage and reason which
started publishing in 1968 within the
first couple of issues was espousing
both of those positions so you you know
the progressive left caught up to us the
Republicans are starting to catch up to
us talk a little bit about uh in the 70s
so you know normal as as a as a group is
hugely important and kind of really
setting the conversation for marijuana
legalization there's also cultural
changes going on and how what is the
interplay between culture and politics
when it comes to drug laws part and I
guess we'll use marijuana as an example
in the 70s you also had the rise of High
Times magazine which was not just a
small magazine it became a mass you know
it was selling hundreds of thousands of
copies per issue you had the rise of
performers like Cheech and Chong I mean
if you go back and listen to you know
comedy records from the 50s or 60s
you'll hear people kind of making very
coded uh references to getting high or
smoking weed but then suddenly Cheech
and Chong was able to have top 10 albums
or or singles that had to do with
smoking weed what you know what's the
interplay between culture and politics
when it comes to drugs I mean Nick it's
a great question I think first of all I
think probably
um limited and maybe sometimes two sips
four and three steps back I mean all of
that popular role of marijuana in
popular culture in the 70s did nothing
to prevent what happened post 1979 I
mean you know the Turning of marijuana
began in the last years of Carter there
was a kind of you know adolescent
marijuana use that actually gone up to
something like 10 to 12 percent of all
seniors in high school school said they
were smoking daily which is a legitimate
problem issue that any parent would
simply be concerned about uh folks back
then did not handle that issue you know
these were Lessons Learned for the sort
of next wave that I was the kind of
leader of you know beginning in the 90s
um I would say that the medical
marijuana thing that's where culture
made a difference when we look at you
know when we started doing the medical
marijuana initiatives and you know I
didn't draft the the medical role in
California but I put together the
funding and you know headed up the
campaign because the Grassroots
activists who drafted it did not have
the real will to do that but I'll say
you know then support was maybe 55 maybe
55 to 60 nationally maybe a little under
that and when you go into a ballot
initiative you don't want 55
55 is your is your Baseline you need
yeah I'm 55 to think about moving
forward because he was right I mean but
you you would pres you would prep prefer
to have something like 65 or 75 because
yeah that's right although that would be
unrealistic on most of our issues and
the truth be told sometimes we would get
65 70 percent on on another ballot
initiative area like treatment instead
of incarceration and those numbers would
just melt you know where's the
interesting thing about medical
marijuana we do polling and get 55 and
then you come to election day we get the
same thing or sometimes even better so
medical marijuana tends to stay up but
I'd say that you know one of the most
important things that I think happened
in the late 90s early 2000s that that is
not really measurable is that it wasn't
just our political successes first in
California and then next few years and
you know Alaska Oregon Washington
Colorado divided in Maine and legalizing
marijuana in those States and then
Hawaii it was that the entertainment
media picked up on this issue there was
a period where you could barely turn on
a single TV show whether it was a drama
or comedy without having a medical
marijuana episode from Merck was his
name Murphy Brown to you know all these
other sorts of things major movies I
mean I mean uh Susan Saron did not do a
movie unless she was smoking a joint in
one way or another I mean so I think
that entertain payment culture
legitimizing of marijuana and it being
used typically not by young people not
by Cheech and Chong fans but by older
people using it for medical purposes and
oftentimes cancer AIDS patients right I
mean had because the role of medical
marijuana or the way it was talked about
in helping AIDS wasting syndrome that
was important it helped broaden it out
also for in terms of the gay community
and a range of others but older women
using marijuana to deal with
chemotherapy for breast cancer glaucoma
you would hear a lot you hear glaucoma
but but Nick I'm really stressing that
that visual image of of a woman who's
been I mean that like when we had to do
the ads the tv ads for the prop 215 the
medical marijuana initiative 96 it was a
woman who had come through breast cancer
or it might be her kids it was it was
that sort of thing the glaucoma thing
played the AIDS wasting syndrome play so
that was a place where broader culture
really played on a significant role if I
could make just two of the way your
point about the Libertarians you're
right Libertarians were pivotal you know
reason also Cato I'm like yeah when I
first started stepping out in 87-88 you
know William Buckley and Milton Friedman
were my two of my most prominent allies
I remember speaking at Cato conferences
in 1988 I remember reason you know the
wonderful writer reason uh Jacob sulla
meeting him back in the late 80s and
he's been one of the best journalists
for over 30 years on the drug issue so
libertarian Gary Johnson the first
governor former governor of New Mexico
then is the libertarian Party candidate
so Libertarians and the institutes
reason Kano and even the was it Pacific
Research Institute and Independence and
independent institutes they were putting
out some of the best stuff really smart
solid stuff and also to their credits
this was not so prominent in the early
years but many of the Libertarians in
this issue and especially the
journalists like yourself you know who
initially was give me Pro give me
legalization or I'm not interested in
all the stuff in the middle the harm
reduction the incremental reforms but in
point of fact many of the people from
Jacob solum to Alan Bach the Orange
County editorialist they really began to
get into the nitty-gritty of reforms and
appreciate the importance of incremental
reforms in advancing towards and
ultimately more libertarian objective
right now the other question I want to
respond with Zach's earlier question was
so with marijuana legalization you know
what what does that say for all the
other drugs and by and large I think
there was more sp there was spillover in
two respects the first thing I have to
say though is even as support for
marijuana legalization was going up as
you showed in that Gallup poll if you
looked at the Gallup polls on support
for legalizing all drugs you saw
relatively little movement in the 10 to
15 level you could kick it up if you
rephrase the question but you didn't see
a spillover in that sense what you did
see especially in recent years is the
spillover in probably three respects the
first one is the one that Nick mentioned
before on psychedelics it kind of helped
people ease up it was like almost like
we're asking well if we can legalize
marijuana disguise in Fall what's next
and psychedelics was one of was the next
one the second one was that when we
started to this really began
actually when when uh we almost when I
say we here not me but the broader drug
policy reform movement almost legalized
marijuana in California in 2010. it lost
by a few points did much better than
people expected two years later Colorado
Washington become the first ones the
media covers that not just is marijuana
breaking out from the other drugs they
carry it as a kind of reaction against
the War on Drugs that to support so the
media coverage expands the kind of
broader significance of the thing and
the third one you know ending you know
for drug policy lines for me you know
I'd always kind of hedge when it came to
do we want to legalize all drugs in the
sense of making them legally available
over the counter the way we do with
alcohol cigarettes are now increasingly
with marijuana and I'd hedge on that
issue because of my own personal
uncertainty because I I thought it was
better politics to hedge than not but I
also I'm not a Libertarian libertarian
in that same way I don't have the same
confidence that that's going to lead to
the optimal policy right but when it
came to decriminalizing possession of
small amounts of drugs which was very
much the European model I mean Portugal
but also other places it was been part
of dpa's you know Mission since the very
beginning but nothing we could really
move forward with politically but when
my successors at DPA in 2020 work with
local Advocates to decriminalize
marijuana in Oregon and win that by a
substantial margin actually it that
initiative and the psychedelics
legalization initiative are both on the
ballot in Oregon in 2020 they're both
first-timers they both win by about 55
percent of the vote I mean that is a a
major major breakthrough and by
decriminalization here well there's a
lot of details but it basically boils
down to we don't want to put anybody
behind bars for simple possession of
small amounts of drugs for their own use
if they're not hurting anybody else
that's the essence of decriminalization
and that one is wildly popular
uh no it depends how you frame it how
you sell it you know it just made it
through in Oregon
um you know when you look at the polling
in other states you're getting in the
low 50s maybe mid 50s you're getting
what we do with medical marijuana but
whereas medical marijuana has that thing
that people could relate to and
especially the older women and they
shift the imagery the decrim thing you
know like don't arrest people most
Americans going back even to the late
90s Nick would say we don't want to put
people in behind bars uh if they get
picked up for possession of a little bit
of heroin cocaine or Methamphetamine for
the self the first couple of times but
we want to make sure we're shoving them
into treatment and if they don't quit
we're gonna lock them up and the sad
thing is is that even up to today most
Americans it hasn't shifted that much it
can feel like well you know yes we don't
want to lock them up the first time want
to give them chances give them treatment
but the notion of letting of letting it
be like it's not anybody's business not
the government's business and that's why
Oregon was a breakthrough and one has to
move very carefully in that area because
the devil is in the details and you get
all sorts of you know unfortunate
opponents yeah and we just very quickly
I'm sorry Zach let's show that slide of
how different types of drug use breaks
down uh you know kind of Lifetime annual
and uh monthly and you know kind of in
the past 30 days is a kind of shorthand
for a casual user um certain drugs don't
really work the same way but if we're
looking at this this is uh a drug user
ship among Americans age 12 and older
yeah for drug abuse statistics yeah so
this is you know this is government data
uh and it's it's widely accepted but 46
of of Americans ages 12 and older have
said they've used weed at least once in
their lifetime 18 in the past year about
12 in the past month but then when you
start looking at things like cocaine 14
18 percent in the lifetime two percent
in the past year seven tenths of one
percent in the past month LSD only 10
percent of Americans say they've used it
one percent in the past year two tenths
of one percent in the past year uh when
we look at things like heroin and these
numbers are remarkably stable every year
2.3 percent have used it ever uh three
tenths of one percent in the past year
two tenths of one percent the uh in the
past month and Ethan the reason I bring
uh these numbers up is that just kind of
uh if we can talk a little bit as we
move from discussions of marijuana
legalization to these other drugs part
of it is that these drugs are very
uncommon most people have not ever used
them and certainly don't you know maybe
they did it once and that's it
um yeah how does that factor into the
way that when you're talking about t
criminalizing it's one thing to say oh
we want to decriminalize weed nobody
should go to jail because they have a
couple joints on them but then when you
say somebody's got some heroin on them
or Methamphetamine
um you know and we're not talking about
Adderall or Ritalin then it changes
right I mean because these are
substantially you know there's just like
the when and now when I say culture I
don't mean you know like whether or not
it showed up in That 70s Show but just
the people's familiarity these are very
foreign substances to people yeah yeah I
mean it's basically right so rather than
just simply agreeing with you let me
just pick out a few points and some
nuances here one is that there's
sometimes slight biases in those
government surveys I remember Gary
Johnson the former Governor of Mexico
used to make a joke he said if somebody
called you up in the 70s and asked you
to smoke marijuana yeah man of course I
do even if you didn't somebody holds you
up in the late 80s or 90s and asks you
if you smoke marijuana you don't say
who's calling who wants to know I'm not
telling you anything right so you have
kind of and we're back in an era of
people almost being a little ashamed to
say they never smoke marijuana at times
you know so you get a little upward by
conversely on the heroin heroin cocaine
stuff you know we're in areas where
people don't really want to reveal that
secondly when you're looking at drugs
like heroin such don't forget that those
surveys don't typically count people who
are incarcerated and some significant
percentage people behind bars in fact
have used those drugs but are not there
and some significant number of people
who have died of overdoses and AIDS use
those drugs and they're now dead so they
kind of um you know dead prematurely so
there may be a kind of the numbers may
actually be a little higher than you
would think
um as a result right
um I think but your point you know
cocaine had a period right in the late
70s I mean even you mentioned High Times
as part of the very popular magazine
there was a play where High Times was
thinking of Shifting towards
um I think Focus I think they already
were focusing more on on um on uh
cocaine marijuana and cocaine including
that and I think even normal was
beginning to had some internal
discussions back then about including
cocaine and their advocacy it was seen
with some good reason as a relatively
innocuous drug the potency back in those
days was more like 12 percent pure as
opposed to that 60 or 70 you get in
subsequent decades mostly among middle
upper middle class people who had jobs
and lots of incentives to keep their
drugs was always talked about as
non-addictive yeah seven days for a long
time and there were people mad magazine
and you know Time Life as a series of
Publications that doesn't really matter
anymore but going back to the 40s I mean
was it was it uh was a uh you know the
establishment of American life and they
were generally Pro psychedelic Pro a lot
of drug use including people in Time
Magazine you know they've talked to Cher
who would be like oh yeah yeah cocaine
is great it's a pick-me-up it's a fun
party drug and what's great about it is
it's non-addictive yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so I mean and most people probably
90 of people using it we're not having a
problem and many of those who did have a
problem were able to get out of it
because they had the resources they had
the incentives and Motors once you move
in towards you know people shifting not
just to freebasing cocaine but to
smoking crack cocaine when that emerges
in the mid 80s and when the population
of users in the in the media's eye
shifts very dramatically to poorer black
people in the cities and of the
criminality involved with that
um and you know people are much fewer
abilities and centers and resources to
keep their drug use under control that's
when you see a major shift and powder
cocaine which is becoming more potent
really gets swept up in that gets more
and more demonized and the other thing
of course I mean look I'm no fan of
cocaine I've never particularly enjoyed
it you know I probably did it a few
dozen times when I was younger always
seemed to me like drinking too much
coffee and having post nasal drip I mean
you know I I realized I had friends who
would become poets when they do cocaine
and people who love it but it doesn't
bring out the best in people it's not
quite the opposite and so that drug I
think had a well-deserved reputation for
not being a great people drug human drug
you know maybe it's good for pets but
not for not for people yeah yeah for
pets and you know one can make an
argument uh you know right before sex
um but uh but for socializing and things
like that um there's a work drug uh you
know no no no no no and in a way if you
think about it you know Ritalin Adderall
you know which are being prescribed have
been prescribed for decades now in very
large numbers to Young you know to boys
basically and some girls but you know
younger people you know and it's helped
a lot and it's been over prescribed as
well in a lot of cases
um but as I understand it if you were to
take that little little riddle or
Adderall pills or those other things
that they're giving high school kids or
younger and if you were to ground it
down and smoke it or inject it the
effect would be pretty damn similar to
injecting or smoking methamphetamine you
know with all the you know problems of
keeping your drug users under control
and addiction and health and all that
sort of stuff and conversely if you were
to take that methamphetamine and make it
available in five milligram pills in the
way that ritalin or Adderall is at a
comparable dose it would be pretty damn
similar to the Adderall and Ritalin so a
lot of this is about the labeling of
drugs my understanding is meth has
certain properties that are a bit
different but that by and large it has
far more to do the amphetamines and
Other Drugs but especially amphetamines
has far more to do with the potency and
the form of administration than it does
with whether it's this stimulant or that
stimulant and certainly the media plays
a very big role in shaping our attitudes
towards particular drugs as well as
drugs in general well Nick the way I
like to frame it to people is you know
imagine
um uh you know an editor at a local
newspaper says to one of his top
reporters look I'm going to give you a
few weeks I want you to write for me uh
do we're gonna do a multi-part piece
about alcohol in our community and the
reporter goes out any and he basically
goes and he visits the 12-step programs
and the rowdiest bars and the jails and
you know all this kind of stuff and he
comes back and he has this devastating
portrait of alcohol in the local
community and the editor looks at and
goes now wait a second and you know it
goes did you go to the did you go to The
Vineyards that are in our community did
you go to the high-end bar what about
the 90 of people who don't have a
problem with alcohol they opens up his
own you know side draw and pulls out of
his own flask right and then he says to
the guy okay I want to do the same thing
on methamphetamine and the journalist
goes out and he visits you know once
again the treatment programs the jails
the you know what have you and it comes
back right to this devastating portrait
of methamphetamine and the the item goes
yes perfect great love it he doesn't
stop to say well wait a second what
about all the people using
methamphetamine who aren't in the
treatment programs they're in jails
who's recruiting new methamphetamine
users because obviously not going to
people whose teeth are falling out all
this sort of stuff right I mean who's
doing the kind of snowball research what
academics call snowball research where
you find one person in a community doing
something like using math and then you
ask to meet his friends and then ask the
friends to meet their friends so you'll
find all sorts of people who may have no
contact with the treatment system or
with the JL criminal justice system so
that's a fundamental bias and Distortion
in the way that we think about this
issue and perceive this issue it's not
to give these drugs a pass it's just to
say that we see in full Glory all the
horrific sides of these drugs but we
know almost nothing about the massive
people who are using these drugs in more
modest or moderate ways or not getting
in trouble or getting in trouble and out
of trouble without ever coming into
contact with treatment or criminal
justice systems and Ethan you know you
mentioned earlier that when we're
talking about these drugs that have the
potential to have much worse outcomes
that you know harm reduction is really
the approach that has come to the fore
um decriminalization and that the
details of how it's done are really
important and so I'd like to dig into
some of those details first at the
federal level and then down in at the
state level and then looking at some
International examples but you know
since the uh this graph shows that
there's been a shift at the federal
level in drug policy that began during
the Obama years and the red line here
shows the amount of federal drugs
control spending going towards Supply
reduction so that is typically you know
cracking down on drug dealers arresting
people interdiction is what they call it
demand reduction is the green line which
Justin you know
2016 there surpasses uh Supply reduction
and that has more to do with
treatments getting people not dependent
on these drugs anymore this is another
way to look at it from the National Drug
control
website so that blue slice there this is
the latest federal drug control budget
from 2022 which is 39 billion dollars
39.3 billion dollars and about half of
that is treatment that big blue wedge
and then the orange wedge there is
prevention so more than half now is
going to treatment and prevention the
yellow wedges domestic law enforcement
and uh the green is interdiction so it's
still you know not a small number going
towards kind of the traditional drug war
activities but my question laying all
that data out is
has this shift at the federal level had
any effect and if so what yeah well Zach
I mean first of all you know some of
these numbers are a bit suspect right
because there are political reasons
where even Republican governments in the
past have wanted to claim that they're
that they're spending more on treatment
or listen and interdiction so what gets
counted has varied from year to year uh
you saw even in the Bush Administration
you saw a drop in spending if you pull
that chart up again you'll see a drop in
spending on the enforcement side the the
uh yeah you see that one between 2002 to
five and that I think was just a change
in the way they were calculating things
for political reasons right now the
other question I don't know in that
thing is probably the single greatest
change in terms of actual dollars was
that Obamacare uh significantly
increased access to drug treatment for
people right because it began to provide
higher levels of coverage for people who
are struggling and it requires certain
things I don't know I am assuming that
that big jump in treatment money is a
reflection of the Obamacare care what
opens up as opposed to Dedicated drug
treatment money but it also could
reflect the fact that you know not just
in Obama but even if you think about it
you know under Trump very little in the
way of bipartisan legislation went
through Congress and got signed by
President Trump but there were two major
bills I think in 2018 that did just that
one was one to get rid of mandatory or
reduce mandatory minimums and Drug
sentences and the other was one to
really up the level of resources for
dealing with the opioid addiction issue
and the overdose crisis where even
Republicans were saying let's spend some
more money on this they weren't ready to
spend as much money as Democrats but you
know it did increase it did increase
substantially so those were the key
factors but keep in mind when you're
talking about harm reduction the federal
government's been a [__] disaster
um I mean quite frankly it wasn't until
you begin to see support for harm
reduction really during the Obama
Administration but even he does not use
the word and the Trump Administration
definitely doesn't want to use it it's
only Biden who believes in harm
reduction personally less than Obama did
who finally uses it you know who hires a
a former West Virginia drug czar who's
been pro-harm reduction to some extent
could you very quickly just Define harm
reduction yeah and why is it a why is it
a different and better approach to drug
policy concerns it's basically Nick I
mean it's typically contrasted with an
abstinence-only approach right and it's
great Advantage it's two major
advantages one is it's basically just
common sense human nature pragmatism the
other thing is that there's Oodles of
evidence showing that it tends to be
highly effective and more effective than
abstinence only approaches right so harm
reduction really emerges around needle
exchange programs and and access to
sterile syringes and pharmacies in order
to reduce the spread of HIV AIDS back in
the 80s and 90s and the Europeans
Pioneer this stuff and the US is very
slow you know you know bit by bit
tragically slow we basically allow a
quarter million people to get infected
and die whereas if we had rapidly you
know embraced access to sterile syringes
through pharmacies and needle exchange
programs when the Europeans and
Australians and others did probably well
over a hundred thousand fewer people
would have died in this country so it
but that's the essence of harm reduction
but it's obviously more broadly it's a
broader notion it's the notion of um you
know if you're gonna people are going to
get get drunk make sure you have a
designated driver it's the notion if
you're going to play football or ride a
motorcycle or a bicycle wear a helmet
it's put the goddamn seat belt on it's
just anything that reduces the risks and
harms associated with people engaging in
a potentially risky or harmful Behavior
just damn common sense it applies in in
so many areas of life if you're going to
do psychedelics you know don't do it at
a big concert don't do it with strangers
don't do it in the middle of the city do
it with people you're comfortable with
if you're going to do MDMA make sure you
hydrate make sure you know
as opposed to saying you shouldn't you
shouldn't be doing any of this so we're
not going to give you any guidance on
how to do it more responsibly the
mainstream view is don't do it don't do
it don't do it the best way to get out
of a problem is to stop which is true on
some level but doesn't really mean very
much to people who are caught up in it
and the other thing is that if you do
have a problem the abstinence only
approach is basically in America it's a
12-step approach which is if you have a
problem with one drug you have to stop
using all drugs forever and in America
we combine the 12-step approach with the
coercion of the criminal justice system
so we take an ideological model of
Alcoholics Anonymous which has helped a
lot of people but doesn't work for the
vast majority and we attach criminal
sanctions to people who can't cut it who
fall off the wagon the harm reduction
approach is look any as if I'm a
treatment provider if I'm somebody
trying to help you know and the best way
to say it is with a 12-step approach
somebody knocks on your door 4 at a
12-step treatment program and that
person says there are you ready to stop
using drugs now because I can't help you
unless you're ready to stop using drugs
and if that person says no I'm not ready
or no I don't think I can then that that
staff person says well go away and come
back when you're ready right and the
result of course is that many people
went away and substantly died of an
overdose or Aids the harm reduction
approach says listen
um I'm not putting in a conditions here
except if I'm going to let you in my
program you can't be an [__] to the
people here my basic thing I want to
know is what do you want to accomplish
in your life what are you trying to do I
mean are you trying to stabilize your
life you're trying to regain custom your
kids you're trying to get a real job
you're trying I mean what are you trying
to do let's focus on what it is you want
to accomplish in your life and then
let's figure out the ways in which your
drug use is getting in the way of that
and maybe stopping entirely if you can
do that is great but if you can't maybe
you just got to use less maybe you got
to not use when your kids are around
maybe you gotta only get high on the
weekends maybe you got did you only do
in the evenings maybe you gotta you know
all the kind of price maybe you got to
shift from injecting to smoking or from
smoking to an oral form all the
different ways you know in tobacco I
don't know if we're going to get into
this but obviously shifting from smoking
cigarettes to taking on you know them
e-cigarettes or these heated heated
tobacco products vaping you're still
addicted to the underlying nicotine but
you've now reduced the risk to yourself
To Us by 90 95 percent and if you can
move to using those pouches you know the
nicotine pouches the uh Zen and on and
all these other sorts of things you know
you reduce the risk even more it's all
that's that's the essence of harm
reduction the federal government has
been incredibly backward and it's only
now under Biden that we see them
publicly embracing it under Obama you
saw them at the United Nations level
beginning to quietly support some of
this stuff but even the drugs are was a
bit reluctant now you see a bigger
Embrace but once again I mean sure we'll
get into this later fentanyl comes
around it kind of changes the story and
we still need harm reduction and also
the old knee-jerk impulse is you know
let's interdict let's lock up let's
increase penalties let's do mandatory
minimums not just Republicans but even
the bidens of the world you know even
even the Democratic governors of the
world who just say politically even if I
know it's the wrong thing to do I still
feel compelled to say I'm going to do it
and what one of the most uh robust
empirical findings from harm reduction
seems to be what you mentioned earlier
with reducing disease transmission
through injectable drugs this is an
example of a very early study around
Yale where they tracked all the needles
in the local community and found a
reduction of by a third of HIV
infections and I mean that's been
replicated over the years that's also
one of the strongest findings out of
Portugal which we'll get to a little bit
later there is a critique of harm
reduction action that I'm sure you've
heard that often comes from people who
are involved with the treatment system
and and the rehab system uh I went to
Oregon after they passed measure 110
um which decriminalized all drugs in in
the state and this was I think you
probably agree the most uh kind of the
the biggest step forward in that regard
in any single state within America
um and I talked to some of the people
who were involved with that I also
talked with a treatment provider who was
critical and I just wanted to play a
clip from that documentary to kick off a
little bit of discussion about some of
the pushback we've been seeing to
decriminalization and harm reduction
lately
and once again at the Vanguard of reform
in February it enacted a law ending
prison sentences for all types of drug
use and possession whether it be cocaine
meth heroin or psychedelics in 2019
before this new law was passed in a
Statewide referendum more than 4 000
people were convicted of drug possession
and organ and many more cut deals with
prosecutors allowing them to avoid a
conviction in exchange for supervised
probation and some rehab with the new
law not only does possession bring
nothing more than a hundred dollar
ticket defendants can get them dismissed
if they place just one phone call to a
drug abuse assessment hotline so far
only 29 people ticketed for possession
have placed that call according to the
non-profit that runs the hotline the
lack of accountability built into the
measure that would be my concern is that
we see a bunch of money in the system
that isn't having an effect Mike
Marshall who has a personal history with
alcoholism and meth use is executive
director of organ recovers which lobbies
for more funding for addiction tree
treatment and opposed measure 110. I'm
worried about the person living on the
street in the tent right outside this
window whose smoke and meth all day long
and they're destroying their system we
need to to have a system of care to take
care of them
so there's really two issues that Mike
Marshall's raising there
um that you can take them separately uh
one is that uh he believes that this
decriminalization was implemented
without setting up a more robust
treatment system first and there's some
evidence to Bear out uh in in the years
that have passed since that that path
that passed in 2020 went into effect in
2021 and there's reports that people who
want to access treatment are unable to
and so Mike Marshall says they should
have flipped this they should have
funded the treatment first set up a
really robust treatment system and then
decriminalized
um and then his second one has to do
with incentives that there's no longer a
way to sort of push people into
treatments by issuing them citations or
whatnot
um take one or both yeah I mean Zach I
mean I'll say a number of things about
this I mean the first one is you know
the notion uh I mean the people who come
from an ideological perspective and
believe in abstinence only treatment
they're just going to resist anything on
an ideological basis regardless I mean
we have dealt with resistance from the
abstinence only Treatment Community
forever and ever and ever and it's just
something you know sometimes they
finally come along as a younger
generation of people where harm
reduction is just more part of the
discourse and common understanding so I
think that's a matter of change it's
just going to happen secondly when you
pass a breakthrough initiative like this
it's been true with every initiative
we've done it's probably true in all the
other areas as well these things don't
easily get implemented they're doing
something brand new so rolling these
things out getting it right whether it
was with medical marijuana marijuana
legalization criminal justice reforms
treatment instead of incarceration or
take a whole range of other areas that I
don't know about but when you're doing
something for the first time in a major
way and you're changing a system in a
key way the the rollouts are going to be
immensely challenging I mean to say oh
it worked perfectly it rolled out
perfectly it's everything we expected
that that's just fantasy it doesn't
happen that way thirdly when you look at
say the way Portugal the pioneered this
policy 30 years 20 years ago the early
2000s you know they didn't say let's set
up the treatment first and then do that
they do the two things simultaneously
you know you end the criminalization of
possession and you're changing the
systems approach as well right I mean so
you do both of those sorts of things
fourthly there's no place in America
whether it's Oregon and California or
even wealthy cities that have fully
enough access to treatment these things
can be expensive one thing about harm
reduction is that all you know people
talk about we need quote-unquote
treatment beds most people with a drug
problem don't need a treatment bed and
treatment quote-unquote beds are
expensive very very expensive you want
to reach people and and and and
hopefully you know be able to help that
when that fellow you had there Mike
Marshall says I'm worried about the
people on the streets and we need to
help them that's exactly what the people
who supported the initiative were saying
right there's nothing special about that
so you know I I think you know you get
this Old Guard resistance but the
information I've seen in terms of lives
being saved in terms of the money
eventually getting out there and the
ways intended remember a lot of the
money is coming from marijuana tax
revenue so it's not even as if taxpayers
are paying generic taxpayers they're
paying more they dedicated some of the
marijuana tax revenue over the
objections of some of my Allied
marijuana reformers to providing harm
reduction and treatment services so
you're having a substantial increase in
the state of Oregon of funding for
services to help people stress you know
struggling with drugs and that's the
bottom line there fewer people going to
jail crime not going up as a result of
the initiative and more people getting
help is it going to be perfect no is it
a major transformation that sets a model
for other states in the country in the
same way that the European countries
provided a model for what Oregon did yes
Zach can we talk a little bit about the
the outcomes in Oregon and Portugal well
okay so I mean one of the concerns with
Oregon specifically is that there has
been a spike in
um overdoses uh since it was
decriminalized uh hold on try to find
the slide here number 15.
right but exactly the key point there of
course is that there's been a spike in
overdoses virtually throughout the
entire country regardless if they were
pursuing more liberal policies or more
you know Crackdown policies I mean
that's and that's a major Game Changer
has been Fentanyl and a fentanyl's
beginning to show up or showing up in a
major way in an area you know fentanyl
did not show up across the country all
at one time but when it shows up
remember fentanyl's special right until
before a fentyl emerged when people or
the media would write about a heroin
overdose very few people died just from
taking too much heroin most of what was
called a heroin overdose right or
another opioid you've typically involved
using heroin in combination with alcohol
or in combination with tranquilizer
benzodiazepine type drugs they would
have more accurately been called fatal
drug combinations right or accidental
drug you know dust resulting from that
fentanyl changes the game because
fentanyl is 50 to 100 times the potency
of heroin and the result means that you
don't need to combine fentanyl Other
Drug you just need to get that you know
by itself and you can die of an overdose
you know you stop breathing and so when
that happens that can really change the
figures substantially
um you know the slide that I just pulled
up here shows the National Drug involved
overdose deaths uh 1999 through 2021 and
you see there's a light gray line that's
way above all the other ones that's
synthetic opioids I.E primarily fentanyl
it says in parentheses so that gives
everyone
a idea of the scope of how much fentanyl
is driving the overdose crisis that we
is that everybody agrees is is real and
uh substantial but uh can we go back to
Oregon though because you had pulled up
a slide as well that in Oregon itself
overdoses are up 20 right yes year over
year so you know Ethan is is that you
know is that because fentanyl has shown
up in Oregon now is it because people
who drugs have moved to Oregon or is it
that you know we have to look at
decriminalization and wonder you know is
this is this part of the uh you know
early application of of a policy that I
think all of three of us certainly are
in favor of well I mean one thing one
Florida context I think for this is you
look at a lot of the Western European
countries where harm reduction has been
part of overall policy in a more
substantial and radical in the United
States for now 30 years and they don't
have the overdose issue we have I mean
it just doesn't exist there and it's
part of it's because it's part of our
broader system and Fentanyl of course is
also not really shown up there except in
a few kind of you know a few cities
um so that's first secondly the
initiative passed in November 20.
rolling this thing out we're barely two
years unless it's years since the
implementation of this stuff it's far
far too early to evaluate way something
or hold a change initiative which you
can see are our media things we're also
you see fewer arrests happening for
example that's obviously going to be a
direct reaction to law if you see more
people going to get help because there
are more resources available that's
obviously going to be a result of the
law right if you see shifts in tax
revenue or how tax rate those are
obviously direct results but when you
want to look and try to evaluate this in
terms of the broader health of a drug
using population isolating that out the
early rollout stage of an initiative
from the consequence of fentanyl being
out and about all over the place
um you know never mind the impact of the
pandemic and the effect that that had on
higher overdose rates and drug use rates
and all this sort of stuff there's too
many variables so I think the people who
want to try to attack it I've seen DPA
drug policy lines and others put out
some pretty good reports basically
showing the ways in which this has
generally worked and been quite
effective and my understanding is that
you know the public is remaining fairly
supportive in Oregon of the initiative
you know I remember in Colorado and
Oregon when they started in Colorado
Washington when they started rolling out
people were going ah this doesn't work
it doesn't work we can't do you know it
was all about the rollout issues but
when actually you checked with the
public the public was saying no we
thought we did the right thing the
public support remains strong so I mean
another line of criticism that I've
heard from Mike Marshall but also others
is that Oregon should have learned more
from Portugal because Portugal did a
better job at first setting up like a
more robust treatment system here's some
numbers out of Portugal by the way so
2000 is when uh decriminalization went
into effect that the red line at the
bottom is Portugal this is death drug
deaths per hundred thousand the blue
line is EU you see Portugal plunging in
drug deaths after decriminalization and
then in recent years probably due to
fentanyl there's been an up I think
actually probably not fentanyl it may be
more stimulant drugs coming in and
things like that and that also happens
when Portugal goes through that economic
crisis uh you know so there are other
issues going on there but it is true
that Portugal still has less than half
the number of drug overdose deaths uh
than other countries there you go yeah
so it is you know by any measure it
would be considered if if you want to be
you know if you want if you're going to
have a drug overdose uh you're going to
have half less less than half as many in
Portugal than in any of the other EU
countries yeah and just to run through
some of the so this is uh the prisoner
sentence for drug offenses plunges in
Portugal over time uh HIV diagnoses
attributed to injecting drugs which we
talked about earlier
plunges dramatically
um you know there the the the the
critics who's uh the critics who are pro
decriminalization but skeptical of what
organ is doing doing points are reports
like this this is a report from the
Swedish government basically that
studied Portugal and said that it's not
just the abolition of penalties for
using and possessing small quantities of
drugs there was also efforts regarding
rapid and effective treatment and also
coordination between various Health Care
interventions
um you know both use and possession for
personal use are still prohibited but
the penalties been moved from the legal
system to an administrative one and so
they use that uh to if if you get caught
in possession of drugs they can send you
before this Commission of a social
worker a psychologist and a lawyer and
then they decide you know does this
person have a substance abuse problem if
so we're going to recommend them
treatment and then if they don't accept
that recommendation they can actually
issue
um a sanction uh so it's more of a it's
more of a heavy-handed approach and you
know as a as a Libertarian I'm it's not
the most pleasing thing to hear but it's
something to Grapple with the the fact
that that is you know kind of the
highest profile example of um you know
all drug decriminalization has a little
bit more of a heavy-handed system
before you start I mean again going back
to the the libertarian side of things
and when I think of people like Thomas
saws the great critic of medicalization
of society and whatnot who who resisted
medical marijuana on the grounds that it
was all it was doing was increasing the
the ability of the state to police
people's personal lives things like that
we need to recognize those of us who are
pure legalizers that Portugal and most
of Europe and most of the success
stories they actually they haven't
legalized drugs in any way shape or form
that we tend to have a discussion in the
United States and so a black market also
persists in Portugal because they have
not legalized
a bunch of points on that I mean firstly
you know it's interesting the first
report about the Portugal model uh 15 or
more years ago in the United States was
published by Cato and written by Glenn
Greenwald you know of intercept Fame and
Brazil and all this sort of stuff and in
it he basically emphasized the
decriminalization and gave short shrift
to the kind of increased access to
helping Services right and um and then
there were some corrective reports came
out and one of the the leading academic
reports were by a British academic Alex
Hughes and Australian Kate Alex Stevens
in a Australian uh researcher Caitlyn
Hughes published in British general
criminology where they did a much more
in-depth analysis and they pointed out
it was really both pieces of this right
right the second thing of course is that
it's remember Zach it's not about these
commissions
um they're not about sending people to
treatment I mean what they're basically
doing this figure out how do we need how
can we help this person does this person
need to go to an employment counselor
does this person you know they would say
a lot of a lot of people who are
committed drug juicers if you say go to
treatment they don't want to go to
treatment but if the person on a
commission goes Hey listen I see those
marks on your arms it looks like they're
getting some abscesses some infections
there why don't you go and see a doctor
to have that your abscess is checked out
and they and then a drug user will go to
a doctor rather than a treatment person
and then the commissioned person calls
the doctor and says by the way here's
what's going on when you look at the guy
you know it's a more subtle approach
it's focused not on achieving abstinence
and more and helping people get their
lives together be less of a burden and
Troublesome to the community and get
their stuff together right they might
reach out to their families they might
do things like that so understand it's
not about we almost in America almost
reflexively say treatment treatment but
a lot of what it is is about you know I
mean look the vast majority of people
who quit smoking in America didn't go
through treatment programs and you know
cigarettes are more addictive than
heroin right so I mean you know it's
understanding this sort of thing and
then thirdly you know to Nick's point
about you know Thomas SAS and he and I
became quite friendly in the 90s and um
and but we would debate one another and
I remember when we uh when we won the
medical marijuana initiative Tom was my
leading critic this is going to be the
medicalization of marijuana you're
empowering the doctors they're worse
than the prison guards and all this sort
of stuff and I would say Tom you're
crazy man I mean first of all the whole
system the federal government's not even
allow people doctors write prescriptions
for these things it's a much more
informal thing secondly the medical
system is so much less pernicious than
the criminal justice wanted and thirdly
the medical system is required and
ultimately to it you know they have to
accept certain scientific science-based
arguments it's in a way the criminal
justice system doesn't that can just all
be about public sentiment so it's more
vulnerable to crumbling and in the end
you know I was right he was wrong and I
think in this case you're alive he's
dead so yeah you won it's across the
board I wouldn't even give Tom that much
credit here even if he was still alive
I'm still writing still be wrong because
the ultimately the fact was look at the
marijuana thing the whole medicalization
thing opened it up towards broader
legalization without resulting in
anything that Tom would have feared and
I think the Portugal model it's very
much the same thing doctors play only a
modest role in this stuff it's not
medicalization it's not all even that
heavy-handed right I mean I I have to
get help I have more sympathy for saza's
concerns about the medicalization or uh
you know what Michelle Foucault who was
also friendly with Tom sawz in the 70s
when Foucault was at the University of
Buffalo and size was at the New York
State Medical Center in Syracuse you
know worrying about different forms of
kind of large controls over individual
lives but I I agree with you Ethan
um Zach could we show you know in in a
more like American context one of the
problems here and this has a lot to do
with drug policy is the rollout in
reforms and what we have seen in places
like San Francisco is where there has
been decriminalization or whether it's
you know Deja Ray or de facto
decriminalization of drugs you get
open-air drug markets and things like
that and then you have critics like
Michael schellenberger who I think makes
a very powerful case that we're not
doing what Portugal did and instead we
have a disaster unfolding that is likely
to blow back on those of us who want to
see the drug laws liberalize um Zach can
we run that clip I think you could get
rid of drug dealing or drug use without
a severe curtailment of our civil
liberties which nobody not even the most
fascist really in our society would
support but you can disallow open drug
scenes which is the the homeless
encampments you can disallow open-air
drug dealing it's hard but it is we do
know how to do it which is that you
basically suppress any
um you know you see one dealer and one
addict making a sale on the street
that's not a priority for police but
once it becomes known and part of the
problem is that like addicts if you live
in Cleveland like you know that San
Francisco is a place that you can go to
and use heroin openly and freely in a
low cost and so when you shut that
opener drug scene down an open drug
dealing down it massively improves the
security of the neighborhoods
so this speaks to uh fear that I've seen
a lot even when we were mentioning we're
going to have this conversation it's
been expressed in the comments that if
you decriminalize all drugs in America
every city is going to turn into San
Francisco or Portland
um and there's going to be you know tent
cities everywhere so does that need to
be
part of the conversation with drug
decriminalization and
how do you address that well I mean yeah
it was something Michael Schellenberg
saying um you know when it comes to the
issue about the open-air drug markets
right that's one conversation and then
when it comes to what do you do about
all the people who are using drugs and
others and that's where Michael is
ultimately incredibly disingenuous full
of [__] recommending policies that are
internally incoherent and all this sort
of stuff and playing on people's fears
around this stuff so I think that when
it comes to you know increase like
Michael's coming out against say Michael
schellenberger became a leading opponent
to Safe injection sites right supervised
consumptions that just seems the
opposite of what he's talking about
about public drug use what we know based
upon Decades of evidence from 60 cities
around the world throughout Europe now
Australia Canada Etc is that when you
open up a safe injection site or is now
called an overdose prevention center or
supervised consumption room right that
basically which are essentially needle
exchange programs with a back room and a
nurse where people can't get their drugs
there but they can bring in drugs
they've obtained elsewhere and then use
them there what you find in the evidence
is first of all it eliminates over those
fatalities right there has not been
there have been I think tens or hundreds
of thousands of people who you know have
now around the world hadn't suffered an
overdose in one of these facilities not
one of whom has died never mind the
people who would have died out on the
streets right secondly what it does is
it enables people to begin to improve
their health right there's a kind of
quiet place where they can be right
where they're where they're not on the
streets right where they're behind and
they can get a cup of coffee maybe wash
their clothes maybe talk to a counselor
you know and have a safe place to use
their drug and then chill out somewhere
right thirdly the evidence shows that
they significantly reduce the public
nuisance the open-air drug problem you
find fewer used syringes on the streets
when you have a safer injection site you
see less of that kind of drug dealers
because those consumption sites have an
incentive to try to you know keep the
people who come to their facilities from
being involved in drug stuff on the
streets right so that though his
opposition to supervise consumption
sites just as antithetical to everything
we're talking about including what he
and I and everybody else agrees with
which is that you can't allow open-air
drug markets now the question about
open-air drug markets that's a different
one you know and that's something where
I look for example what happened another
European model they called it the
Frankfurt model beginning 30 years ago
where they had a major problems with
open air drug dealing and drug using in
some of the parks in Frankfurt and
otherwise and what the mayor did was
basically set up a Monday morning group
where she had to head a police that had
a prosecution the head of Health
Services the head of Social Services
that have Housing Services and a few of
the top people and at that meeting it
was like okay what's the focus here and
the police would say well we're thinking
of having a little Crackdown in this
neighborhood there you know and then the
queen of Mayor said well so what are we
going to do with the people that you're
picking up and then it would be well can
housing take them can this take them it
was a coordinated policy of the source
that for example Temple mayor London
breed in San Francisco has totally
abdicated has totally failed right it's
not nobody I mean I was just in San
Francisco last week you look at the
open-air scenes going on there and it's
unsightly it's problematic nobody wants
to accept that you look what happened in
Europe and I think somewhat has happened
in New York as well a lot of that
remember New York used to have big
open-air drug markets right part of what
happened was a policing strategy which
pushed people off the streets I mean a
de facto policy that said that if drug
use or even selling is happening behind
closed doors and we're not getting
complaints it's not open air it's not
messing with a sense of community
security we're not getting complaints
from Neighbors then that becomes a low
priority for us the key to dealing with
open-air drug markets is not getting rid
of drug use because you can't do that or
you can only try to reduce it through
other programs the key is pushing that
stuff indoors in ways that don't harm
the rest of the community right that's
the in Roger they called it the
Rotterdam like dealer program or
something where the the police knew
that's what you had to do right and then
the other thing is is distinguishing in
policing among the problematic people
involved in dealing and the less
problematic or what I would call the
series between the [__] dealers and
the non-assle dealers if somebody if you
got a guy running a local Bodega
and under the table they're selling a
little heroin or cocaine or whatever to
their local the same people you know
shop in their stores it's a kind of
under the table it's quiet they know
their customers they're not selling
their kids basically from a policing
perspective you want to basically turn a
blind eye to that stuff conversely if
somebody's out there on the streets and
they're Hawking this stuff or they're
they're harassing people walking by
they're making people feel unsafe or
they're selling the kids or things like
that that should be a number one
priority of the cops the cops should be
stopping those people they should be
arresting those people and if those
people don't want to take some service
except some kind of helping service then
those people need to be put off the
streets in a serious way
schellenberger's approach is idiotic
because he takes a real problem about
public drug use where we need real
solutions and then he does something
like opposing safe injection sites which
is the opposite of what you'd want to be
doing in order to deal with open-air
drug use if I may just uh from a recent
live stream we had Bill Bratton on who
was Police Commissioner in New York in
the mid 90s widely credited with
reducing crime here and again under Bill
de Blasio from 2012 2014 or 2014 2016.
and he was complaining in in terms uh
Ethan that you are kind of replicating
here of where he was saying you know the
problem in New York is that ever you
know people are making marijuana deals
so all over the place there's there's
food carts everywhere selling marijuana
there's people on the streets and I was
like well you know it's legal here but
no we there is they haven't rolled out
the retail so it has to happen on the
streets because they haven't opened up
storefronts like if you know when's the
last time you saw somebody buying Liquor
on the street it's like you don't have
to do it or you go into a liquor store
yeah you know on I mean it's very tough
for me and I really kind of avoid coming
publicly because the fellow Chris
Alexander who's running the New York
State Office of cannabis management is
very good guy he used to work with me a
drug policy Alliance you know my
organization drug policy Alliance you
know really LED played major role in New
York adopting probably the most you know
thoughtful Progressive well thought out
got the best law in the country but the
implementation well the implementation
is and and so you know now just last
week I saw that a bunch of of cannabis
companies are suing the New York state
for you know that going beyond what the
law requires in ways that actually you
know borderline being illegal so we'll
have to see where that happens and it's
been hobbled because somebody sued you
know that was unrelated to the whole
issue here and that's prevented the
rollout of Brooklyn and a whole bunch of
Upstate counties so it's a complicated
thing New York every state has had
problems with rollout and remember also
when we legalized alcohol in 1933 a
limited alcohol prohibition and Most
states banned it I mean Most states
allowed it then it's not as if you
switched your fingers everybody's going
illegal liquor Atlas you still had
well-established criminal networks that
did not want to give up their markets
you had the organized crime trying to
shift into the distribution side of
things when they're neurally involved in
production you know you had the legal
market now trying to compete with the
illegal Market by for example offering
corn whiskey which had not been a thing
before prohibition but now people
developed a taste for it right I mean
these things I I once started
researching an article when I was still
teaching in Princeton whatever happened
to the black market in Boones and it
didn't just poof go away it takes time
and I think if you go 10 years forward
the black market in campus is going to
be substantially smaller than it is now
and remember part of the black market if
some of that black market is just people
growing their own which is legal in Most
states and sharing
um with friends or maybe even selling a
little that's not that's not a problem
that's not an issue what we're talking
about in New York is not even what they
call the Legacy people involved in the
market for 10 15 20 years and are like
you know are they going to make the
transition or can they do the regulatory
requirements which is tough for them the
bigger problem is a lot of outlets which
were not involved in the marijuana
business you know for 10 or 15 years
that in this kind of gray area window we
have between full legalization and
implementation they're taking advantage
of a lot of factors including the
slowness of the state and giving
licenses to entities that are ready to
up and go and I mean that'll that
stuff's going to work itself out it's
the same thing when Zach was showing
Oregon these are all rollout issues you
know the world doesn't change that
quickly I do want to point to a great
book that's about 10 years old now maybe
a dozen years old by Garrett Peck called
prohibition hangover which is one of the
few books that was came out from Rutgers
University press it's still available on
Amazon and whatnot that actually looked
at what happened at after prohibition
ended it's a phenomenal history as is
also an Ethan I know you spoke to her on
your podcast psychoactive I've
interviewed her for a reason Lisa mcgear
is the war on alcohol because we do have
this sense that you know Roosevelt gets
elected and in 1933 prohibition is
repealed and then suddenly we're living
in a world of micro breweries and you
know a
gastropubs and it literally took half a
century or more before we kind of got to
an equilibrium in terms of licking
alcohol you know this was another
standout book there on back in the late
80s I read a book by David kivek a
professor kyvig called repealing
national prohibition and that was really
a template um for for me and thinking
about how to build a drug policy reform
model and I remember introducing the
book to the heads of the drug policy
Foundation the founders then uh Kevin
Zees and Arnold tree back and they've
been using that model on their stuff it
was a beautiful book because one of the
things it shows was that the movement to
repeal alcohol prohibition brought
together people who had remarkably
different varying views about what was
most wrong with prohibition why they
cared about it most and remarkably very
infused about what should come in its
place but they all came together to end
prohibition and inevitably there were
going to be conflicts and differences
once it came to you know figuring out
the details there after but that you
know and that really was for me a model
like I'm gonna you know when I was
building drug policy Alliance movement
bring together people from the left the
right and the center people only care
about this drug or that drug people
coming from racial Justice from HIV
prevention from a Libertarian
perspective bring it all together and
then once we kind of really win it then
we can take out the knives and fight
over the details about how we're going
to roll it out and implement it but the
bigger issue was getting rid of
prohibition and you know that's a a
great moment to plug your your legacy
and all of this you built a massively
broad Coalition and I think some of the
earlier marijuana groups were also
involved in that kind of stuff
um and it's Libertarians always talk
about baptist Bootlegger coalitions
where it's people who come together to
[__] over the legalization of something
because you know they're benefiting in
one way either ideologically or
economically from something you're
talking about the flip side of that do
you worry that in the current drug
legalization movement particularly
related to marijuana but also to other
drugs that other issues the Legacy
institutions including drug policy
Alliance are they you know they're
sensing that they've they've got the
window you know the Arc of history is
bending towards them are they more are
they Less open to these wide-ranging
trans ideological coalitions to get
stuff done in the short term well you
have to distinguish between say
marijuana policy project which was you
know focused really on marijuana
legalization as and the same with normal
where they're essentially victims of
their own success they're at a point now
where there's remarkably little
philanthropic money left out there you
know once this stuff becomes legal a lot
of the philanthropists start saying Hey
listen I don't want to pay for this when
people are making money for it so you
know I'm going to focus other things and
you deal with the industry and so
marijuana policy project I don't know
what normal is doing in that regard but
it means that it becomes very hard to
raise the philanthropic money
um and that ultimately ends up shaping
the nature of the laws that get passed
the ballot initiatives they get drafted
it also means that where you still have
an ongoing problem of marijuana
prohibition persisting with high levels
of arrest and high levels of racial bias
as in the South and a range of other
places it means the philanthropic money
you know unfortunately you know is not
stepping out I'll also say philanthropic
money
um from the foundations were always
Dreadful when it came to supporting
marijuana reform I mean I raised almost
all my money for marijuana reform from
wealthy individuals George Soros Peter
Lewis John Sperling Bob Wilson you know
Bernard sells uh you know I mean you a
whole range of from across the political
Spectrum right the foundations the Fords
and the whole range of them they were
terrible they were on the marijuana
issue they were useless and even as they
began to fund criminal justice that the
staffers I mean they had their own
Hang-Ups on that issue now when it comes
to the broader issue of Coalition
building and whether or not say DPA and
others will maintain that broad base I
think in psychedelics I mean you know
part of this is generational I think
that if you look say it um the Rick
Dublin the founder and leader of uh you
know Maps you know which is now the
biggest drug policy reform organization
in the world I mean he's very committed
to doing this across the board he and I
speak the same language it's all about
that a younger generation and especially
a generation which came up under Trump
which you know made made the whole
bipartisan thing a lot more difficult
than it was in my day but even before
Trump there was already a growing
resistance I saw it on the left and I
think the same things are happening on
the right to doing that kind of you know
across the Spectrum you know broad tent
bipartisanship stuff it's just not part
of the the same ways of thinking in a
way and so Nick I think you've heard me
talk about this we've been in a few
public settings but you know one thing
I'm trying to talk to younger activists
about is one of the things that I think
made us successful with drug policy
reform was our communication our
realization that we don't win unless we
persuade the ordinary American middle of
the road parent that what we're saying
about marijuana or other drugs is more
persuasive than what the other side is
that means speaking a language it means
not using Progressive speak and that
means not using not just academic
language but Lefty type language you
know it means not putting your identity
first you put the message first right
these are all sorts of things that seem
to have been lost or dismissed among a
younger generation of activists which
take great pride in some of the
remarkable Transformations they can
cause in states that are places cities
and states that are already Progressive
but which may effectively in my mind be
handing over the country to the Neil
fascists who are speaking a language
that sometimes you know appeals even
more than the Lefty language does so you
know I I think it's it is a real risk
but I think it's not about the changing
of the issue I think it's a generational
shift and it's also because a reflection
of the broader but both a cause and a
reflection of the broader polarization
or society which is unfortunately shape
the communication side of things in
terms of how Libertarians talk about
drug League legalization uh and I I
wonder if it
might make sense to talk more just kind
of as a closing topic here about full-on
commercial legalization because we've
talked you know a lot of the the kind of
politics and you know what is possible
it's like we were we talked a lot about
treatment and decriminalization but
there's kind of a case that I think was
being made there about if you think
about the effects of prohibition the the
fact that it's prohibition itself that
is both making these drugs more
dangerous and also creating some of the
disorder on the streets that maybe it
would make sense for America to actually
LeapFrog places like Europe and Canada
and go for all-out legalization and uh
we're Nick was sharing this piece with
me earlier uh by the late uh Dan Baum in
Harper's magazine called Legalize It All
and um I thought this could be a way to
kick off this conversation he writes
that just about everybody who thinks
seriously about the end of drug
prohibition agrees that we'll want to
discourage consumption I mean that we
can put that aside for a second but the
goal could be accomplished at least in
part under a system of regulated
for-profit stores by setting limits on
advertising and promotion for Banning
the or Banning them all together by
preventing marketing to children by
establishing minimum distances from
schools for retail outlets by nailing
down The rules about dosage and Purity
and by limiting both the number of
stores and their hours of operation and
so bomb here is basically proposing
treat these hypothetical
all you can buy drug stores the same way
you might treat highly regulated liquor
store does that strike you as a
plausible and good model
well I mean first of all politically I
think it's neither here nor there I just
don't see the support I mean as we point
out before Zach even as the numbers Rose
from marijuana legalization and now in
psychedelics we're not seeing the same
type of change I think the one the
country that comes closest to the open
dinosaur model maybe Switzerland
actually where the numbers have been you
know 35 40 percent in the past but even
there they're accustomed to having a
fairly hyper regulatory system and so
they might and they've had a lot of
success in varying ways with that sort
of system there's a greater cultural
tolerance for it the United States we
don't have the kind of tolerance for
those sorts of models I mean
periodically we had you know post
prohibition with States having you know
liquor monopolies and things like that
but it's not the kind of thing that one
can see really working in America where
we tend to Veer between moralistic
prohibitionist extremes on the one hand
or like Let It All roll you know like
you know you look at European they want
to legalize gambling they still you know
the casinos are regulated they you know
the the state lottos and all this are
saying in the United States when we go
from Probe legalization you know we
start you know having casinos open 24 7
with all sorts of incentives to you know
keep gambling and stuff and we do start
doing lotto and we're hiring AG
companies Design La ads that
specifically appeal to addictive
personalities I mean so we don't do that
middle ground thing secondly I'll tell
you one of my principal ways of of
thinking about legalization it gives me
pause
is I think about you know what some
people would oftentimes describe as the
three most powerful addictive and
omnipresent drugs in human society and
what are those sugar fat salt sugar fat
salt sugar fat salt right now you look
at what sort of multinational food
producing companies have been able to do
on that front right where they're doing
stuff with brain chemistry and they're
figuring out the exact combinations of
the sensual taste in the mouth and the
texture of the sugar fence all
combinations you know we're junk food
not just because of what they're
producing but has become enormously
popular in all sorts of ways and
appealing and you know it's especially
an issue with poor people but this is
becoming more and more of a universal
phenomenon not just the United States
right and you see that obesity the
consequences obesity the estimate now is
possible that obesity now results in a
greater loss of life and of of you know
dollars lost than just either smoking or
all illicit drugs put together right so
and that's happened quite dramatically
in the last 20 or 30 years so if I begin
to imagine a legal system where
pharmaceutical companies can um you know
do what the food companies have doing
and sort of be coming up with all sorts
of neat drug combinations that
specifically generate some level of
dependence but don't do that much harm
at least in the short term that's my
great fear about what could happen there
when I look at a model for legalization
the one that I think comes closest is
one that actually before you go on there
let me just ask
um if that is your fear would that
actually be a worse situation than we
are in right now given the level of
death that is happening from fentanyl
which is the fact that fentanyl is on
the streets is purely a byproduct of the
black market well it's no that's the
right question Zach you know how do we
compare these relative risks right in
fact you know 30 years ago I put there
in the working group at Princeton
um the Princeton working group on on the
future drug use alternate drug
prohibition and I published a piece
called thinking seriously about
alternatives to drug Prohibition in the
journal the academic Journal Daedalus 30
years ago which really hashed out all of
these you can find it online but it's
you know it really hashed out all these
issues how do we balance the competing
values at stake including the question
that you just posed right now the
question is is would that in fact
um you know solve the federal issue
um it might it might do that
um you know you know if if you would ask
me the same question four or five years
ago or maybe four or five years from now
if the fentanyl issue diminishes a lot
would that change the calculation but
Zach the thing I point out is there is
actually a model that emerged and was
actually enacted into law but never
implemented and about 10 15 years ago
New Zealand had a major problem with
synthetic cannabinoids right and people
were getting in trouble with it stores
were popping up unregulated and what
eventually happened was the two biggest
manufacturers of the synthetic
cannabinoids which was kind of not
legally regulated but not legal they
approach the government and the health
Ministry and they say we have a mutual
interest here we know our products are
relatively safe we've done the testing
but we don't like all these fly-by-night
companies and all these pop-up retail
outlets and so and we have a mutual
interest in getting rid of these so what
they proposed and what New Zealand
Parliament enacted with like 110 to one
vote was a system setting up basically
an FDA like entity that we're
pharmaceutical companies or anybody
could submit a drug that they had
created to this new fda-like entity and
if they could establish a substantial
margin of safety the government would
approve it for over-the-counter retail
sale to adults even though it had no
accepted medical use so it's like the
FDA thing without requiring medical use
just showing substantial margin of
safety and the people behind that
including in the government understood
that what they were proposing to do for
synthetic cannabis might well be a model
that could apply more broadly to all
other drugs as well now unfortunately
the law was never implemented for
ridiculous reasons when people caring
about animal rights protesters they
didn't want to have drugs being tested
on animals and all things shut down but
the fact is the drug that law is still
on the books you know the United Nations
controlled board and our cars control
board shortly freaks out about any
reform didn't really quite know what to
do about it so I think that's the
potential regulatory model which might
make a lot of sense and remember also
it's also about like if you're going to
legalize cocaine are you going to
legalize it only in a kind of cocaine
coca-t version which has cocaine in it
or like you know chewing gums and and
sodas like liquid forms are you going to
legalize the sale of 10 pure potency
powder for snorting are you going to
allow it to be sold in injectable or
smokable forms
um if you only allow it to be sold in
the less potent forms um would you then
uh you know crack down on people who are
selling it in you know who could you
know turn cocaine that they bought at a
pharmacy or a store into crack would you
then crack down on them for selling it
in the pre-made crack forms so I mean
the organization in the UK uh transform
you put up one of their slides before
and their public policy specialist Steve
rolls of rol well yes he was the last of
my 80 interviews on my podcast
psychoactive he's really done some of
the most
um you know Advanced thinking on this
stuff he's I tease him about being sort
of a hyper regulator
um which is true it's you know but he's
actually thinking hard about what
regulatory models might make sense for
what sorts of drugs and they have a new
volume that came out in the last year
about how to legalize stimulants which
is the hardest you know we can figure it
out for cannabis psychedelics maybe even
for opioids but the stimulant drugs are
the ones the cocaine methamphetamine are
the really really tricky challenging
ones
you would agree though that movements
towards with almost no exceptions
movements towards decriminalization and
legalization
are to be preferred over the status quo
or a rollback of that yeah I mean I mean
almost totally I mean I mean you the
thing is look what I one of the great
advantages of legalization to the extent
that legalization is synonymous with
legal regulation and that's something
that some old-fashioned Libertarians
recoil at but when you define
legalization as legal regulation right
you know one arguments I typically made
is that people think of prohibition as
the ultimate form of Regulation when in
fact prohibition represents the
abdication of Regulation anything that's
not being effectively prohibited is
basically lies outside and is totally
unregulated controlled by gangsters
criminals you know blah blah blah so
when it means when legalization is
synonymous with legal regulation and
when that legal regulation is pragmatic
not overly heavy-handed not not dumb not
which inevitably regulations become dumb
and backward in some areas but where the
essence of it is constructive and
conforms the local culture well I think
that is almost always
um a step forward right yeah I I don't
want you know underground synthetic
drugs being sold we don't want you know
you know well you don't want them to be
underground but maybe you want them to
be sold but then the people who sell
them you know if they're acting in open
daylight they can be you know they can
be found they can be sued they can be
held responsible right you want civil
liability exactly it's one of the great
benefits of a legal regulatory system is
you have civil liability for the harms
that are caused and you know some
synthetic cannabinoids may be perfectly
fine other things but you know the stuff
where people are using now with the
xylazine this other tranquilizer drug
out of Colombia that's being mixed with
fentanyl and beginning you know
commercial you don't want that all that
crap there but I I know what you're
saying and this goes back to you know
the kind of Thomas saws worldview which
is beautiful and Powerful in its
Simplicity but you know I when I say you
know I would like to live in a world
where all drugs are treated like beer
wine and alcohol often from my fellow
Libertarians I'll be told that I'm awful
because I'm I'm asking for new taxes you
know and new regulations to be written
and it's kind of like yeah I guess so
but you know you know in the big picture
are you [__] kidding but Nick my
perception is a substantial evolution in
the libertarian both libertarian
political libertarian you know where
they no longer say prohibition and
Taxation are the same thing but there's
an understanding and part of that's
political pragmatism you know that
marijuana has been such a great success
and you realize that has to come and
part of this matter that the way you tax
how you tax the levels you tax make a
huge difference you know California got
the taxation system all messed up there
are better and reverse ways to do this
stuff and then ultimately prohibition
represents its own form of tax and it's
a far more onerous one yeah I I worry
you know also talking about the kind of
identitarian left you know where people
are you know will say that the drug war
is absolutely the most racist you know
fraud that's ever been perpetuated on
America since slavery or Jim Crow but we
will we will live under it for a number
of years until we get our specific
demands met in terms of who gets life
licenses who gets this who gets that
it's you know there's a lot of uh
sussing out to be done I think within
the drug reform movement if what we're
trying to do is to make the world better
uh right well and you know Nick that's
just following I mean I remember the
good old days Charlie Rangel the Harlem
congressman who chaired the select
committee are Narcotics back in the 80s
and early 90s yeah and leader of the
Congressional Black Caucus right major
drug Warrior right and when I was out
there arguing for legalization you know
not the same type that Tom says or
Friedman or Buckley were arguing for but
still you know that was the label for
the major reform and you know it was
like Zach was rolling the Oregon stuff
you know Wrangler would be like well
first let's get all the treatment in
place which he knew was never going to
happen there's these were not legitimate
objections to trying to reduce the harms
of prohibition they were just ways of
trying to defend the status quo and
that's what has to change and I think
that and it did with Rangel to his great
credit said I was wrong I was wrong want
to support major sentencing well I don't
know how I will tell you that I remember
him being one of my principal opponents
when I first stepped out in the late 80s
like you know on Nightline and other TV
shows and then we get to the year 2000
and I team up with Ariana Huffington and
we're doing these shadow conventions on
attacking certain issues with the
Democrats and Republicans are pretty
close and there is Jesse Jackson Another
what major reporter of mine and Charlie
Rangel and they're speaking on my day to
oppose the drug war you know and Charlie
Rangel standing up there and saying when
I go to Cuba what am I going to say the
Fidel Castro when he asked me about our
our political prisoners our prisoners of
the War on Drugs so he followed in the
footsteps of a younger generation of
black leadership that was beginning to
play a Vanguard role in the political in
the evolution among elected officials
yeah
one last question uh before we uh bring
the stream to a close I you know do you
have any hope that there will be non an
ultra Progressive cities that start
implementing some of these reforms in a
serious way in the near future we were
if we're talking about broadening the
political coalitions
um you know it's it's great to the
degree that
um San Francisco or Portland OR Seattle
start implementing this stuff and
showing what works and what doesn't work
well Zach I think the answer is I mean
there's two ways one is that what you
saw eventually on needle exchange
programs was that they got embraced I
mean the great example of that is in
Indiana when all of a sudden a city had
a huge outbreak of HIV Among Us ejecting
drug users and first the health people
say we got to do that finally they got
the conservative police Chiefs to say it
and the governor then was Mike Pence
before he was vice president and he was
opposed to post he's always been opposed
and you know he's got the police chief
and everybody's saying do it do it do it
do it we've got to save lives a priority
and finally Mike Pence says he had a
conversation with God and God told him
his right thing do so he gave it a kind
of qualified green light so you do have
those examples and then on the overdose
issue
um that's one you know where it has over
the last decade been basically hitting
poor lower middle class white the kind
of you know death of Despair type thing
um in a significant way and that's for
some rethinking there there's a
wonderful group um a harm reduction in
Ohio might even be its name
um and uh started by a guy
um I'm going to space on his name right
now who was the uh he was actually a
journalist he was a journalist covering
the drug issue and other issues for USA
Today
um back in the day and you know so you
see even in Ohio people are trying to
figure out how to do the right thing you
know people don't want to have you know
the people they know dying and dead like
that so that's opened up you know ears
and harm reduction naloxone drug testing
things that kind of right-wing
prosecutors and others were always
opposed to so I do have some optimism
it's a shame it moves so slowly in that
front
um but I think there is evidence of
movement there
all right we are going to leave it there
we have been talking with Ethan nadelman
uh formerly of the drug policy Alliance
uh and also of psychoactive podcasts
which is still available to consume
pretty much everywhere without their
Nick yeah without tax or regulation this
is it's fully legal uh you have what how
many episodes did you do it's not even
taxed or regulated it's free you know
how many episodes I did 80 episodes from
the summer of of 21 until about a month
and a half ago I'm taking a break now
and I hope I'll be back later this year
or next year that's fantastic it's an
incredible Archive of voices uh I highly
recommend it uh thank you so much for uh
sharing your uh wisdom and knowledge of
this season as well as your aspirations
and Zach wise Miller thank you for uh
doing what you do at reason this has
been the reason live stream so come back
uh next Thursday we're going to be
talking thank you always great to talk
with you bye-bye